how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about Marvel and
all things relating to the MCU for all
the Star Wars fans out there happy Star
Wars day happy May 4th if you did not
catch the news there is some major Star
Wars news a new film has been announced
if you want to check it out you can
check out my Star Wars channel cosmic
culture where me and my buddy Chris talk
about Star Wars DC and a bunch of other
awesome movies I'll link it up above and
down below as well and again happy Star
Wars day now today we have some news
about spider-man 3 and what the future
could hold for spider-man and the MCU
now not much is really known about
spider-man 3 there have been some rumors
going around that offer us some hints of
what could happen and many people think
that Kraven the hunter is definitely
going to be the villain and on the other
hand some people think that he could be
dealing with the sinister six however
nothing has really been revealed or
confirmed however recently an actor from
the spider-man franchise has spoken up
on whether or not he's heard anything
about the sinister six so we'll break
down what he said and what it means in
this video if you're new be sure to
subscribe to stay up to date on
everything relating to the MCU I'm also
starting my weekly giveaways today this
week we're giving away an Iron Man Funko
pop exclusive from Amazon to enter be
sure to subscribe to my channel hit the
like button and comment down below so a
couple of weeks ago Michael mando who
plays the character Mac Gargan aka
scorpion who appeared in spider-man
homecoming did a live Q&A on reddit and
of course as expected people asked him
about his involvement with the upcoming
spider-man film spider-man 3
during the QA he was asked hello mister
mando I absolutely loved your work sir
and hope to see you in more movies or TV
shows in the future will you be
appearing in the upcoming spider-man
movie next year in 2021
in which he replied thank you so much
sir I love spider-man and I love that
whole team who knows I keep hearing
things but I can't confirm or deny
anything yet stay tuned
xoxo now based off of this reply it
sounds like he definitely knows
something however spider-man 3 hasn't
really begun development or shooting yet
so he couldn't say anything even if he
wanted to instead what he says he kind
of beats around the bush and
says he's been hearing things and then
says but I can't confirm or deny yet if
you could deny something including your
involvement in a specific movie that's
upcoming you could definitely confirm
that you're not in it so it doesn't
really make that much sense that he
would have to wait till he could deny
his involvement with the film instead
what's more than likely happening here
is that he is involved with it but
production is not nearly anywhere far
long enough for him to reveal his
involvement with it and what's most
likely happening here is that the
sinister six is being set up if we think
back to spider-man homecoming scorpion
was set up for a future appearance in a
very big way especially when he asked
vulture in prison about spider-man's
identity where you could clearly see the
scorpion tattoo on his neck so Marvel
and Sony definitely have plans for him
and now it seems like we have most of
the characters necessary to form the
sinister six and even spider-man
executive producer Amy Pascal has said
that in the MCU right now in the
spider-man films we have everyone we
need for the sinister six
we have vulture shocker tinkerer
scorpion and depending on which way they
would want to go we could have Morbius
as we saw Adrian Toomes aka vulture in
the Morbius trailer and we could also
see venom be a part of it as well or
they could keep venom out of it and used
Kraven the hunter as Kraven is a really
fitting character for spider-man 3 since
he's going to be on the run but if we
put the pieces together take a look at
what some people from sonia said and
take a look at what Marvel and Sony are
doing with Morbius and spider-man it
seems very clear what's going to happen
we have vulture talking to Morbius in
his prison uniform in the Morbius teaser
trailer in prison scorpion asked vulture
about spider-man's identity and then in
the spider-man far from home post credit
scene spider-man's identity was revealed
to be Peter Parker and a vulture has
escaped from prison we can assume that
scorpion has as well and now all of a
sudden all of these people who want
revenge on spider-man know exactly who
he is and now we have an actor from the
sinister six saying that he's been
hearing things but cannot confirm or
deny yet so it does seem like the
sinister six is on its way possibly in
spider-man 3 if not in the next
spider-man film but certainly everything
is set up
kind of perfectly for them to appear in
spider-man 3 but let me know what you
think about this and the comments down
below would you like to see the sinister
six appear in spider-man 3 or would you
like a different villain let me know
what you think don't forget to like the
video and subscribe with notifications
turned on so you can stay up to date on
everything relating to Marvel as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof woof